JLo is glamming up he's NYC streets plus
Drake and Josh
squashed their beef hey friends it is
Friday of a long weekend and we will
hook you up with our new music Friday
pics at the end of the show but first we
got to talk about Jennifer Lopez because
can you please take a look at this Jenny
brought it back to the block rocking fur
and showing off her midriff in New York
City she's on the set of her new music
video for her song amor amor amor the
Bronx Queens shop for 13 hours all over
Soho and that hooded fur coat well that
costs a cool twenty-two thousand dollars
now closing down the Bowery subway stop
JLo also rocked these navy vellore at
lace-up thigh-highs
now Jennifer who has been busy enjoyed
her summer with her man a rod and their
kids has also been hard at work on her
upcoming spanish-language album
here's what she told us about the
project earlier this year it's a
beautiful album I love everybody that
I'm working with and it's just been a
really really good good experience
collaborated with mark on any of this
mark is executive producing it the whole
album va an already executive produced
it we're working on it together and it's
it's been a great time for us now we
know J Lo's style game has always been
strong but who can forget the film that
gave us a funny glimpse into the fashion
world I'm talking about The Devil Wears
Prada
well a newly unearthed deleted scene is
making the rounds today and it's got
fans like me kind of shook let me tell
you why in the scene and hathaways Andy
saves Miranda for being humiliated by
her over-served husband tick look why
don't you get me another drink you'd
have to listen to you wouldn't he little
guy
um excuse me mr. Ravitz yes oh I have
just been dying to ask you if it's true
that George here used to ghostwrite the
editors page of Manhattan no effect in
fact the two of them once University
together and John and my father were
criticized okay so here's the problem if
you're obsessed with the movie then you
know the icy-cold Miranda Priestly would
never do that
thank you is not even in her vocabulary
thank you is not her style I mean that
would have changed the entire movie am i
right
please bore someone else with your
questions that's all all right moving
right along to Drake Bell and Josh Peck
the feud is officially over folks and my
childhood has been restored over the
weekend Drake & Josh crossed paths at
the MTV VMAs and put their whole wedding
drama behind them you'll remember Drake
took to Twitter seemingly ending their
friendship because he apparently was not
invited to Josh's wedding but John
Stamos was well they hugged it out at
the VMAs
visit live right now you're welcome
shopping but it looks like it was just
the beginning of the reunion because
Drake popped back up in Josh's latest
vlog to assure fans there's no mole bad
blood alright guys there you have it
there it is it's all love finally always
been loved are we gonna be like oh well
I just us boys yeah really is rahl back
together and the wedding was pretty
great David Jesus Christ see it's all
love people and we are going to keep
that trend going with our new music
Friday playlist hear the songs I'm lovin
starting with maroon 5 news sultry
single what lovers do Patrice is a--
[Music]
say say hey hey now I love that song
alright meanwhile Jason Derulo is
setting up your Labor Day weekend right
with this banger here's a taste of the
lyric video for his new single if I'm
lucky that's right see Labor Day weekend
folks off to a great start
Thank You Lauren mm but we got one more
for you
finally Hall sees on the run in her new
music new music video for bad at love
check it out why sip on this
[Music]
there you have it folks I hope we set
you off right for the long weekend I
know I'm off to a really great start we
will be back on Tuesday by the way for
the daily Denny and you're not going to
want to miss it because we are
celebrating the bee day of my Queen
Beyonce
so hit subscribe now and stick with ET
online.com this weekend and get chose
celebrity fix and I'll see you next week
I'm bad and I really am though